cent vingt mille mouvement chaque année
et un pic à 135 milles pour l'année 2019
plus que le nombre c'est le bruit lié
aux décollages et atterrissages qui
crispe certaines associations de riz
brun dominant a été marquée jeu prendra
pas part effectivement cet effet qu vide
s'était fait coville qui a eu certes une
phase très calme pendant leur
confinement le mois de mars avril mai
qui s'est terminée par une par une
horreur et mon un sens avec une reprise
d'un trafic incroyablement nerveux
c'est un constat d'échec parce que en
fin de compte on depuis des lustres on
se bat pour essayer d'améliorer la
situation de réduire les nuisances
sonores et en même temps donc bien
qu'ils aient eu des discussions
intéressantes aussi avec les usagers
malgré ça en fait le trafic a continué
d'augmenter et ce qu'on constate aussi
c'est qu'il continue d'augmenter mais
pour l'union des aéro club de toussus
qui rassemble sept aéro clubs et près de
1000 pilotes l'aérodrome de toussus le
noble doit continuer sa mission
on pense que la réduction du nombre de
mouvements et pas du tout la bonne
approche
notre activité est essentiel pour
l'avenir du pays d'avenir aéronautique
et du pays
nous formons non seulement des pilotes
de loisirs mais nous formons aussi des
pilotes qui poursuivent leur formation
pour acquérir une formation de pilote
professionnel
les associations de riverains souhaitent
que les mouvements soient réduits et que
se développe l'utilisation d'avions peu
bruyant une réunion s'est tenue ce lundi
29 mars avec la préfecture des yvelines
pour présenter le projet d'arrêté fixant
les conditions d'utilisation de
l'aérodrome non satisfaits les riverains
se sont positionnés contre usagers et
collectivités ont voté pour